[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting our guest is Colleen
ballinger she's best known as her alter
ego Miranda sings a politically
incorrect tone deaf Fame obsessed red
lipstick personality so we did something
a little bit different on this ear
biscuit for you we decided to ask
Colleen if we could speak to Miranda
directly have a conversation with her
yeah this is like when I guess when
somebody's possessed and you need to
speak to directly to the demon which
I've never done I've never seen it done
it's like kind like a seance kind of
situation that is not what happened but
it's the best analogy I can come up with
not really I mean she just put on
lipstick and a shirt and did her hair a
little bit differently and boom she
transformed right before our eyes but
it's very convincing because when I am
talking to Miranda I do I feel like I'm
talking to a different person
I mean I am it is totally believable
here in person especially the audio will
be yeah see if see if you get that same
sensation we talked to Miranda for a few
minutes and then moved on to talk to
Colleen but one of my favorite things is
reading Miranda's tweets her Twitter
stream was random it's pretty
inexplicable so I was like yes we have
an opportunity to get Miranda to explain
herself so I I think we gained insight
into the psyche of the character and
then you know after a few minutes of
that we had her transform back into
Colleen and had the bulk of our
conversation with the person behind
Miranda and got the psychology behind
you know what what even there's like
three levels of psychology here I was
very fast and I only took one level of
psychology so I tuned out a while ago
when you're explained yeah and I slept a
lot sis Miranda's introduction in 2009
Colleen has traveled the world
performing as Miranda for audiences
literally on multiple continents and
she's garnered just over a hundred and
fifty million views and 1.3 million
subscribers collectively on YouTube and
she's got an extreme cult following
amongst musical theatre in through the
Azusa the list and professionals known
as Murph and ah's and she's currently on
tour through August
and continues to post bi-weekly videos
to both of her YouTube channels so here
it is first our conversation with
Miranda followed by our conversation
with Colleen okay Miranda first thanks
for thanks for coming to the round table
of dim lighting yes of course I do what
I can for the young one okay well this
audience I think skews a little older
I'm talking about you
oh okay I'm gonna take that as a
compliment it is a compliment I'll take
that yeah respect your elders which is
myself do you do any have you done some
podcasting before you've been a guest on
a podcast
yeah on my own podcast at my house I do
podcasts all the time in my bedroom or
with my uncle pets
means like that so I'm very familiar to
podcasts so and then how do you
distribute the pod cat um it just goes
to myself so I just listen to it on a
cassette tape again after I I do it I
felt like a self-analysis type thing yes
so I yeah improvement exactly sub-health
okay yes the top button yes it's
buttoned of course course you're known
for that yes
gotta be conservative okay classy that's
the reason yes of course I gotta be
classy lady I don't want to be
disgusting and be porn and showing off
my body parts and if I unbutton the top
button on my shirt I'd be showing
testicle cracks and that's not
appropriate some make sure that that has
coming up so I don't make them in
stumble so you've never had a like a
wardrobe malfunction no never
I couldn't even dream of it do you think
that would derail your career if you did
well I don't know I I just don't even
see it happening I don't think my career
would get worse I think it would
probably help a little because all the
men would fall in love with me so fast
but you know I'm a respectable lady
standards yes you have standards yes
very high standards of course right
right
how do you know speaking of standards
that you're a good singer or when
someone is a good singer well I know I'm
a good singer because I have ears so I
can hear myself and you know I put video
online and people tell me I'm a good
singer so that's proof of it so that's
how I know I'm a good singer how I know
if someone else is a good singer I
listened to it and decide on my own if
they're good or not and that's the
deciding factor can you give us like a
taste of the pipes yes of course with
the sound of me so for example that's a
really good song that I'm singing about
myself right and it sounded really good
some what about something more current I
mean like something alter yeah how about
a catch a song yeah yeah we're going
down I'm yelling timber you better move
you bad for my hands some throw you down
do you ever / take in karaoke yes I do
um sometimes I do partake in it at my
house some when it's really fun but I
prefer to sing perfectional II in
YouTube videos understood yeah now one
of the things that we've noticed in kind
of stalking you on the Internet is that
you have a pretty active Twitter feed
yes you're very active and we were just
looking at your Twitter feed and we
noticed you've tweeted some things you
know just in the past few months that we
think we would like you to provide some
context for because when we look at them
we can't figure out what you're talking
about
okay so maybe you can help explain these
things easy yeah so here's in no
particular order here's one okay my
mouth tastes like brown yes I'm just
kind of curious if you could kind of
help us understand that you of course
you know how do you know what that is
when you wake up and you're like huh
what's that taste got it Brown you know
when you think of a color and you know
what it tastes like
uh-huh sometimes your mouth tastes like
brown sometimes it tastes like pink that
particular day tastes like Brown and
what's the difference between brown and
pink pink is lighter sweeter more
delicious sort of like a flower Brown is
more dirtier tastes like dirt mud brown
things gravy
no it wasn't gravy like it was a dirty
taste
okay I think I understand how about this
one
I'm awake I just know it but the know
was like in oh yeah we're gonna know
yeah because I know it if you know
something then you know it that's a
definition of knowing something like the
opposite of yes no like when you know it
when you when you knew it and you know
it in your brain so I was awake because
I woke up and I knew it because I was
awake so there you don't that one's
pretty self-explanatory I can't believe
you guys needed me to explain it okay no
offense I'm just saying it seems very
very simple now that ya liked it exactly
uh here's another one I am seeping out
some air that's a good one that's a
really good one it was just one of those
days I felt like air was just seeping
out from all the places so I just
thought I should tell James yes so
sometimes on tenor there are doctors on
tinder there are doctors I think she
means Twitter she calls it titter I
think oh yeah yes the W is silent just
like a jiff and gif people think it's
called one thing but it's really the
other tinner w-with silent
so yes I'm seeping out air out of all
the places just one of those days a lot
of breath a lot of a lot of other themes
hmm okay this one is a little bit longer
and I cannot even begin to figure it out
I like it when I see that it is but you
know them when you can think every once
but again retweet if you agree that was
in that one time of my life for I was
going through some troubles and I
assumed people were thinking the same
way as me so I had to get that off my
chest
did anybody retweet it I got a lot of
retweets everyone know exactly when I
was talking about you know I know no I
don't know and that's why I asked about
it that's why we didn't retweet I'm you
didn't treat oh well we didn't know we
didn't agree well do you agree now that
I've explained it you know you know what
when it's that time well here's an
other tweet I love waking up and
smelling the moist yes that one is so
full you know when you wake up and the
room just smells like sleep no you don't
know that when you've been sweating and
then your sheets are a little bit wet
from sweating oh okay smell that the
sheets have stinky sheets yes okay got
it
that's this I'm talking about stinky
cheese smell wet that's this that's the
smell of moist you know a lot of people
don't like the word moist I don't know
why it's a wonderful want has a lot of
letters in it a lot of vowels and it is
very explanatory of things yeah could
you yeah my voice sheets moist skin
moist meat okay this one's just one word
the tweet was crust yeah that was one
morning I woke up and I found crusts in
my eyes so yes I would sweet a lot right
when you wake up which is I do it was
the first thing I think about is my
Marfan does and I want to update them on
my life and this morning was cross yes
because I was trying to tweet crusts in
my eye oh darn it again and I just
accidentally pushed send too soon but I
think they knew what I was talking about
you know it's very relatable crust
now when you tweet something like that
do people respond with like yeah yeah
they get yes or I love you Miranda or
what are you talking about but those are
just the haters so I don't listen to
them right a lot of those lol's and I'll
Y's and things like that some okay
here's another and just get a few more
mm-hmm this one's all in all caps
uploading my video now yes that one was
that one actually has a bit split
explanation forint uploading my video
right now and you know that had a deeper
meaning behind it you know it was a busy
day I had been thinking about life and
the meaning of life and why we're here
on earth and how to be a good person and
that was the only way I could think to
explain it and I happened to be
uploading my video at the same time so I
killed two birds with one stone with
that one and and you
upload two videos a week yes Mondays and
Thursdays or Moran days and more
Thursdays and how long have you been
doing that
oh wow geez Louise I've been on YouTube
for I think six years five years but um
that Mondays and Thursdays I've been
doing I think for only two years now
maybe three that's pretty good it's
quite a schedule I know but I'm really
good at it and my Marfan does love it
some anything for them um how about this
one I got that scam but I got that scan
but just the word scan with a B on the
end yeah you know when you get think
about one type of sink you came down
with something yeah I'm just gonna if I
got really itchy in places the image
together know when you're itchy it seen
the crevices of your skin's chickenpox
no no Punk's just patchi's shingles
that's and adults hmm never heard of
Shango oh you're talking about scabies
scabies maybe you never heard it called
that that's a new one hmm I think you
might have made that word up what about
tweet I smell that
Cree's mmm CES I smell that crease
crease I smell that crease okay I now
know what's up I just I thought it was
crazy so when you tweet something like
that is it because you just smelled a
crease yeah I do I have to let my
followers know what I'm doing at every
second of the day and that's what tenors
for it's Facebook YouTube
that's so much chill media everyone
wants to know everything I'm up to you
if I smell something taste something eat
something feel something I'm gonna let
them know and at that point you smelled
a crease it's not a crease big-time okay
she smelled that crease yeah the Twitpic
would have been nice for that okay all
right here's that here's the last one
that one slapped the chair and made it
louder yeah that was the
I remember this time specifically I was
sitting on a chair that was plastic and
let her seat out oh yeah it happens that
one slapped the chair and made it louder
so you blamed it on the chair yeah but
that's you know what I'm talking about
points I don't think I have to explain
it much further you're talking about an
air biscuit not an air biscuit exactly
an air biscuit
yes so exactly you know sometimes that
just happens sometimes air seems out but
if you're on different places you get a
different consistency of hearing it and
that one just happened to be super loud
that was really fun some time to let
everyone know about that and others know
how this chair is to your liking it's
good it makes them quiet okay okay okay
so they're happening but it's yep it's
quiet now I don't know if you know but
we have Colleen coming in here and she
follows me everywhere right I kind of
well yeah she's always following me it's
really annoying when she says she
specifically requested more time she
said she wanted she thought that she
would have more to say she must not know
I'm more popular than her oh well okay
well I mean we just want to talk to her
for a few minutes but do you have
anything that you know you like a call
to action for the for the listeners out
there yeah well of course I mean
everyone I'm sure who's listening knows
exactly who I am and loves me already
and if they didn't know which I can't
imagine I'm on tour right now and they
can come see me on tour and meet me and
listen to me singing and what would they
see they would see a live shelf full of
comedy fun laughter singing dancing I
read hate mail so they can know how to
avoid the haters on the internet and the
bullies and right now it's kind of
turning into a self-help tour where I
teach them how to be better people my
audience so it's kind of like a cinema
know it's a really fun tour but you're
like a what a synonym are you know a
cinema for self help to be better yes
got it
yeah so I teach them I'm like the
professor
and I sing songs and I dance and all
these fun things so yeah I hope everyone
can come okay well they already coming
thanks for coming in I think the least
coming thirst I don't know if you want
to if you guys don't want to associate
you know I don't like talking I want to
okay leave well let you leave before she
comes in then okay thank you thanks for
having me guys don't like it soft thanks
for thanks for the time this is great
it's unlike anything we've ever done I'm
sure biggest celebrity you probably had
in this room yeah awestruck and we we
need you to sign the table like every
other celebrity so you can do that right
quick grab the Sharpie over there and
sign that and then I guess we'll just be
waiting for Colleen did it thank you
thank you for having me guys love you so
I'm leaving okay keep in touch no okay
at this point what's happening is we
have Colleen over here just there's a
wiping her face down she asked if she
needed to stay in full Miranda gear for
the for the Miranda part and I was like
that would help me out a lot and I I
think there were a lot of like I just
wish that we had videoed that because
the the tension in the room I think was
the humor of it like but that was funny
well I definitely think you know I I
have seen in a and a couple other
interviews people have requested her to
go into the into the impersonation
mm-hmm without the the getup
and for me I I you know I need I need to
see the lipstick yeah they did without
the lipstick I just did it you know in
the top button okay and now she stopped
wiping her face in her mouth they a lot
of mouth wiping I know but it still
stains my skin like how Colleen is here
look here
I'm here okay so the tire coming off
sure is coming off and the the lipstick
is off kind of as much as it can be off
right now that was that was something
you know it was something we like we
like just laying people's stories bare
okay yes
so was it it was an interesting exercise
for us but I I think that we laid some
tweets bear that's true I've never no
one's ever had me explain any of those
tweets oh well we didn't tell you ahead
of time it's like I could tell there
were a couple where I was like did I say
yeah but I like that I can tell the
wheel starts nice oh no I'm gonna have
to own these tweets well I you know I
was thinking as we were reading these
things too you know if you were to look
at my Twitter feed and ask me what I was
thinking when I tweeted something I
would probably be able to oh yeah okay
well I can tell you what I was doing
that day and why I said that but you
know you are assuming a character and
then tweeting and so you're having to
kind of go through this double step
process that was I mean most of them I
didn't remember tweeting so because a
lot of times I just will tweet something
random and not think about it or look at
it again
but I don't know I was just trying to
come up with explanations as to why this
person would do something so stupid I
mean you've had many years of just
slipping into Miranda yeah right so I
mean I have to how many years are we
talking about since the inception
Miranda was created in December of 2007
okay and I will get into how but I guess
my I'm curious immediately of just that
you know after all these years slipping
into her is kind of like comfortable
skin kind of thing it's yeah it's it's
channeling something you created but
it's how would you characterize the
a persona like what are you channeling I
am channeling so many things over the
arc over the years I feel like Miranda
has just changed so much and evolved
into all of the people that I hate so I
think that's kind of who she is it's
people that um
people that I don't like and a lot of
that is me like it's me from my
childhood and stuff so yeah I guess
that's the the quickest way that I can
answer that is she's kind of all of the
people that I just don't like well you
don't have to answer anything quickly
here because I think we will get into
the genesis of the character and we can
kind of see the the components that way
yeah Miranda but the thing you know we
have a difficult time enough keeping up
with our own you know social networking
just personally but you have a really
active social media presence yeah
as Colleen and as Miranda and you know I
would assume that you've got one of
those things where you can kind of you
know how do you switch between the
Instagram accounts yeah switching
between Instagram accounts is awful
because there's not there's not another
Instagram app that I can use with
Twitter there's all these different
Twitter apps so I have one Twitter app
for me in one Twitter app for Miranda
but Instagram is kind of obnoxious
Facebook like theirs do you ever walk
out and have you ever you know
misappropriated a message from the wrong
purse yes I did it this morning this
morning which way did it go and what do
we did as myself I tweeted from the
kollene account but I tweeted a Miranda
tweet from my account and then I deleted
it
I always realized I did it right away
okay and then I am and then I tweeted
right after that like note to self don't
tweet as Miranda when you are choline
you're an idiot like so you did all take
pictures of it and they save them all
and send them to me whenever they want
to make me feel bad because they know
they know exactly what happened oh yeah
they always why there's no like it was I
was I said something about my video
coming out today and then I put all
these horrible hashtags so they knew it
was for Miranda's hashtag kony2012 and
hashtag blessed and all these things so
it's it's funny it's like your alter ego
hacked yourself yes well that's what
they say that's what the kids say like
they'll say Miranda hacked you Miranda
hacked you so they'll play along which
is nice of them but you took it down and
then repost it which usually I don't do
that usually a I've mica that tweet is
ruined now I can't tweet it as the
person I wanted to tweeted ass and then
I just create something new but this
morning I was tired and I was like I'm
just gonna tweet what I already tweeted
as the wrong person um yeah so do you
get into I it you know what I imagine is
I see Miranda I see you wake up and then
I see your face contort a little bit and
you become Miranda and then you think of
the tweet was a method actor like I'm
not I just kind of sit there I'm like
that would be really annoying and I
tweet that or I look at my Twitter feed
and look at the tweets that I'm like oh
why did you tweet that person that I
don't know and then I'll wager eyes it
yeah plagiarize the other so I don't
actually come up with anything on my own
it's I just steal it from people so what
do we want to do right do we want to
hear the Miranda origin story or the
choline origin story first well I think
we're compressing to origin stories into
one podcast and two interviews into one
podcast also so why don't we get the why
don't we get the sort of brief version
of okay where you from where you come
when you know where you come from what
was your family like leading up to that
to that you know the the moment that
Miranda would yeah right
I was born in Santa Barbara California
in November I guess I can tell you the
exact day November 21st 1986 Wednesday
probably really cool if you were I've
been so impressed I hope it was a
Wednesday I'm gonna go home and look and
so did the soap opera exist Santa
Barbara the soap opera like when you
were growing up there I don't know
because I didn't know that there was a
soap opera called Santa Barbara the soap
opera is there really a Santa Barbara
soap oh I
don't quote me on it but I'm pretty sure
I mean I'm sure you're right I don't
I don't watch soap operas but that's
really cool I didn't know I'm pretty
sure there was a Santa Barbara so you
know more about survivors than I do
I mean I'll text my mom but with the
time change it would wake her up I'll
talk to her about it tomorrow okay I
mean I was young and the restless' man
but I was aware of one called Santa
Barbara but not being familiar with that
what does it mean for you to grow up in
Santa Barbara to me it means you're in a
soap opera what does it mean to you hmm
it means you're in a soap opera no it's
Santa Barbara's awesome I was really
lucky because it's beautiful there it's
like absolutely beautiful you grow up by
the beach or you can just drive ten
minutes up the mountain and look like a
barefoot kid running around in vineyards
really not vineyards but the beach I was
at the beach every day and my parents
were really good about making sure I
appreciate it growing up there what did
they do or do they still do it um you
know we just be driving down me what do
they do for a living what Oh what did I
do for a living they meant what they do
to make me appreciate it so um my dad
sells computer parts I don't really know
he never really talked about it he's a
sales manager he's an agent
he sells like tiny tiny computer pieces
that measure small things to put in
computers really yeah so uh he doesn't
talk much about it but he travels a lot
and my mom is a full-time mom but she
she just quit her job she was working at
a private Christian school okay she was
like the everything woman she was the
nurse and the recess monitor and the
principal's assistant and everything
yeah that's what they do and now you
said she were she yeah she stopped doing
that because she wanted to be um you
know closer to her mom and and be there
for us kids even though we're all grown
up I think she just she just wants to be
a mom again you know she was really
hands-on mom all through our childhood
and then she got a job when we all moved
out went to college and I think she just
was like missing being a mom and a
caretaker so she's spends a lot of time
with her mom now and her sister and with
us kids and you have a brother and a
sister who brother is he brothers yeah -
brother - older brother isn't a little
okay and I know at least one of your
brothers in the sister are also active
yeah YouTube is that all three yard well
yeah they both kind of um you know I
talk so highly of YouTube I really like
love working on YouTube and so my sister
was like oh I'll do it for fun and so
she started doing it now she loves it
and my brother just started a YouTube
channel he's a magician and yeah he's
super talented and he's really funny and
he actually comes up with a lot of the
ideas I have for Miranda in my show and
he yeah he's hysterical and so um I was
like you should start a channel too so
he just started one and it's going well
people seem to like it
you know YouTube's a weird little world
and your brother so is it one of your
brothers that has two kids he has three
kids now but yeah what my oldest brother
magician show up in your video yeah
that's my oldest my oldest brother has
three kids and he's out in video she's
awesome
nice it's Miranda and your niece what's
her name Bailey singing let it go we're
singing is that what we're saying
no it's doing it's no man even worse in
terms of guarantee to make me cry Stevie
was like I am seeing should I go you
have to watch this cuz she's coming over
tonight am like Oh guys I'm crying I'm
sure I can't cry right here she's so
cute she's the cutest my little niece
Bailey she's so dramatic she's such a
performer and I'm stoked because I have
a show in Santa Barbara
and she's singing in it and sometimes
the kids will come to shows like they
drove to Utah had a so shows in Utah
recently and the kids drove up the whole
family drove up and the kids loved
performing with Miranda any gonna stay
in character so it's just like she was
doing the absolute cutest thing you
could see on the Internet and your face
is Miranda's face is pressed up against
hers and it's just giving her these
dirty looks like you're stealing my show
I know she did so good I was really
nervous about it because I have a really
good relationship with my niece and
nephews and I just I adore them and it
always makes me nervous to be Miranda on
them because Miranda
mean yeah and I never want to hurt their
feelings because I mean to them like
when I'm in character I'm yeah awful and
they love it they think it's so funny
they just laugh they just get a kick out
of it yeah they don't take it personally
right which is good and what they're
more mature than Miranda is really
what's happening yeah well I think the
the my own niece gets it she's six but
my four-year-old nephew is still trying
to figure it out then they call me
auntie panties and he's like are you
Miranda like yes they buy your auntie
panties too right yes he's like are you
real but I was two people he doesn't
quite get it yet I don't think like he
doesn't really know if he thinks
Miranda's funny he just like thinks
they're both me it's must be very
confused trying to reconcile it all
right yeah yeah so what about your
family
led to your you know interest in the
arts were your parents yeah into that my
parents weren't into it all my oldest
brother magician I mean he had been
doing magic and performing that way my
whole childhood I saw him do that but my
grandpa actually was the one who got me
really into theater and performing my
grandparents used to take me to shows
all the time growing up and they were
just always really encouraging of me
trying to sing and act and they never
pushed it they just saw that I loved it
um and I was really supportive and my
grandpa when I was a little little
little he'd be like you're gonna be on
that stage one day I'm you know my
grandpa really really encouraged me to
do it and yeah he's awesome that's who
it was my parents aren't performers at
all really no not at all they're super
shy and you know at my shows kids go up
to my parents and they want pictures of
my parents cuz they've seen them in
vlogs and stuff and my dad gets so
awkward he's like I don't want to go out
he hides in my dressing room he say I
don't wanna go out there I'm scared
they'll take a picture I guess it just
feels so awkward like what do they want
to picture with me I don't understand
like he doesn't get it my kid sells some
really small computer parts
[Music]
oh yeah there there we got on that so
you're your grandfather helps shape your
aspirations to become a performer yeah
and that's as a singer I mean I will get
to it but the thing that I kind of had
to gain perspective on was your
background was to be a singer and then
you kind of discovered this character
right
and so the comedian thing wasn't really
on the radar it was more of you want to
be a singer and stage performer question
mark yeah no that's true
I I wanted to actually to do opera like
I I was trained classically I went to
Azusa Pacific University it's a college
kind of near LA and I studied vocal
performance and I wanted to do opera and
then I quickly realized that I didn't
want to do opera I wanted to do musical
theater but I still majored in vocal
performance and got classical training
and then I just started auditioning for
stuff in theater anything that I could
and I was making these videos as a total
joke you know on the side for my friends
to laugh at and then they started going
viral but and so this was after college
it was actually during college during my
senior year okay was when I started
making Miranda videos and I post them
once every couple months whenever my
friends and my choir would be like oh
you should cover this song as your weird
character and at that point I was
getting like 15 views you know my most
viewed video was like 70 views I wasn't
doing it to be on YouTube you know I
wasn't I didn't know what it was I
didn't know what a youtuber was the
first one the first one that went viral
is what everyone thinks the first one
the first one you made mm-hmm the first
about that the first one I ever made was
I'm dreaming of a white Christmas and
it's not public anymore
because it's so different from what
Miranda is now mm-hmm it's super super
subtle like the wasn't you know the
comedy that I like is really subtle
comedy and that's I wanted people to
believe she was real I wanted people to
think this is a real girl who wants
people who are you thinking about
because I saw that my numbers were you
know I knew I had two friends watching
the video that I'd sent it to but they
were getting 20 views and I was like
there are other people
watching this that I don't know and I
wanted them to think it was a real
person but the motive in making the
video at all
take me back they are who are you making
the video for I was making a video for
my friends in choir there's a couple
friends in particular because YouTube
had just I just had discovered YouTube
and I would search for songs that I was
singing for auditions or whatever to see
if I could find anyone singing them and
what I found was girls singing in their
bedrooms to the camera which I had never
seen before I was so like thrown off by
the idea of someone just talking to a
camera or singing to a camera alone in
their room that was such a foreign
concept to me and I thought it was so
weird and these girls were trying to get
famous by doing this you know they're
like well I'm gonna help this is helping
my career to post videos online and I
just was like this is ridiculous you
can't get famous from YouTube like this
is so bizarre and there were girls that
I went to school with that the character
is based on there was a few different
girls that I went to school with who
were mean just rude girls who were so
cocky and drove me insane and so I was
kind of poking fun at them and at this
the idea of being a youtuber because I
just didn't understand it so you you
decided to make a video making fun of
them and then you were going to send it
to him no no I actually started the
first couple of videos I made I just
recorded privately and sent them to my
friends I didn't post them anywhere and
they were lip synching videos because
those were the first videos I saw on
YouTube that I thought were where people
lip-synching to songs like what is the
point of that you're not even showing a
talent you're just moving your mouth and
so I really I didn't get that so my
first few videos that I made were I sent
that I sent my friends were private they
weren't on YouTube at all I don't even
think I have those anymore
and they're like these are so funny she
put them online and so then that's why I
started posting them on the Internet
they're like you see if anyone sees them
so I just started posting them on the
internet every once in a while and so
did the girls that you made these videos
for originally they were also in school
with you right yeah same program so they
also they also knew the type of girl or
the girls that you were kind of making
fun of in creating the character yeah
yeah I mean well are you asking if the
girls that I'm kind of poking fun at I
knew the girls that you're doing a for
that they were like oh yeah I know
exactly the way yeah yeah but yeah did
those girls who you were using to kind
of come up with the idea did they find
out ever find out about it
well they've seen the videos I mean that
was my biggest fear when the video
started going viral was those girls are
gonna see this and they're gonna know
I'm making fun of them because I like
direct quotes from things that they had
said in sectionals or things they had
said to me or things they had said in
their own videos like I was directly
quoting and imitating these people and
so but you know like hey guys it's me
Miranda um like every single video I
said hey guys it's me Miranda and that
is something I took from a girl who says
that exact phrase but replace my name
with her name and she says it in that
tone
like in videos or in purse okay and
she's seen the videos and she's been
like I don't get it but congratulations
you know she did she doesn't know that
it's you know I think the thing is that
I said I don't get it but congratulation
you were like frantically writing that I
think that the girls that I'm imitating
are you know they're like Miranda so
they would never assume it was about
themself I quickly realized that and
then I was okay because at first I
panicked a bit right there's an American
Idol audition type of thing that I
you're kind of describing on a personal
collegiate level but I don't know if
that was a point of reference for you
just the the people auditioning who
didn't realize how horrible the lack of
self-awareness yeah yeah I think that is
that's just that describes Miranda I
think she's just just just a lack of
self-awareness that's a perfect
description of her because she thinks
she's the most beautiful talented person
in the world and it's quite the opposite
so two views turns into 20 and you're
like okay there's 18 people I don't know
watching this thing well the comments
were what made me be like oh someone out
like I got my first
a comment that was it you suck you're
not that good and you're rude and I was
like I don't know who that is like I
don't know this person and I don't I
don't know how they found my video but
this is funny and that kind of egged me
on to keep doing it I don't know why I
just I really I wanted people to not
like this character I didn't want her to
have any likeable traits at first and
then well it'd have changed and then I
mean I definitely noticed going back and
looking at those that first year or so
of videos that the the very early videos
were very subtle yeah and you kind of
slowly started turned into a clown
amping it up and I think that you know
the first one that really popped for you
of course was the free singing lesson
yeah free voice lessons and you look at
the like dislike ratio on that and you
immediately understand that a lot of
people totally thought it was rude yeah
and that's you know so yeah that was all
intentional that was intentional for
sure and in the beginning because that
was a you had already been doing it a
year before it we started a pop mmm-hmm
so when that video went viral everyone
did think it was real and that's why it
went viral because people wanted to
spread like oh look how stupid this girl
is you know we love to hate as America
and that's everyone was spreading this
video on Facebook this idiot girl trying
to give a voice lesson she sucks and I
thought it was so funny so I actually
was really crazy about making sure my
name was deleted from everything like
people slowly started to find
information on me and put it in the
comments or posted in blogs and stuff
and I was crazy about making sure it was
always deleted and once I started doing
live appearances I would walk to the
venue in character I would stay in
character the entire time never break
and leave just the whole time as Miranda
I didn't want anyone to think that she
could have been of character yet because
that was the key to the success of like
continuing and right at that point
that's what that's why people were
watching and I saw that I was a people
are watching because they think she's
real in the hater if they know that it's
fake no one's gonna watch anymore so I
was really really
picky about making sure no one knew who
I was
okay so we're interested in when you
made the switch to kind of embracing her
as a like coming out as she's a
character but that happened after you
started doing live performances Helen so
how did that happen it went from one
viral video to typical I mean people are
on YouTube for many years before they
feel that they've got the confidence or
the fan base to step right and do
touring right you were like oh I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna do this live show
right now right well my videos were
really popular in the musical theater
community especially in New York City
and in the West End in London and I was
getting a lot of emails that first week
that that free voice lesson video got
popular from people in New York City who
were like come perform with our Broadway
cast or come perform at my open mic
night people that quickly huh just was
based on the one video yeah they were
all just I mean that's in theater it's
all about networking and they just want
to tell you they like your stuff they
got it
these people got it they got it and they
yeah they did research and found like
old old videos of me singing like in
college and so I would ml some people I
got an email from the cast of Mamma Mia
broadcast and Jim Crusoe who runs a cast
party like an open mic night in New York
City at a jazz club and a couple other
little things like that and so I was
working at Disneyland at the time and
doing what I was singing I was in high
school musical and I was just like I
think I'm just gonna go to New York like
I think I'm just gonna go meet these
people because at that point they were
just like hey we think you're funny if
you're ever here you should come hang
out and it was just kind of that it
wasn't really anything more and I
thought this is my 15 minutes you know I
might as well go take advantage of it
did you have to quit the Disneyland gig
no I got someone to cover my shifts for
a week oh and I just flew out to New
York City with every penny that I had
and performed on The Lion King stage and
performed with the cast of Mamma Mia and
performed at jazz club and what was the
context that they created for they were
did you know because if you're there
doing something serious or whatever
Miranda gets up there in the crowd
doesn't know what's going on right
exactly well and that was kind of that
was kind of fun because it's not like
that now but back then no one really
knew who I was it wasn't you know when I
say viral video it's not like how a
viral video is now where it gets
millions and millions of hits it was
like a few hundred thousand you know and
so it wasn't like crazy viral just it
was viral within the community yeah but
when I walked on stage for it was a
benefit it was a Broadway benefit
performance in all the different casts
on Broadway performed to raise money for
whatever charity that year and I
performed with the cast of Mamma Mia and
it was a joke they were taking they were
doing a very serious like interpretive
dance and then Miranda came out and just
kind of ruined it by singing her
horribleness and they all stayed very
serious and stoic and the audience
didn't really know how to respond and it
was funny because I'd walk I walked on
stage and I remember there was like
little pods in the audience and this
huge like huge theater just little pods
where they broke out into laughter
because they knew what it was but the
rest of the audience was just staring at
me like who is this freak on the stage
and like almost like they were in pain
like they were like I don't think we can
laugh like issue is she okay is this
like a charity thing they're doing for
all like right so that was when I'm that
was like when my first times onstage
though I had never done Miranda in front
of anyone before hmm
and then I went over to the open mic
night and performed at this jazz club
and the owner of the club was like you
did great I just improv for five minutes
on stage I didn't have anything planned
they're like we want to give you a night
here at Birdland you can have your own
show do you have a show once a week come
back and do it once a week but they just
like every once in a while come and have
like a cabaret like my own show and I
said you have a show and I was like yes
I can make a show you know I can make
that happen and that's all I knew too so
it wasn't that scary lied but you were
like I will have it now that I've said
that I'm gonna have it it wasn't a lie
it wasn't a lie I just knew that like if
I said no
I would have regretted not doing it and
that's I was comfortable with that
that's what I knew my whole life I've
been performing live on stage so I
didn't know YouTube I didn't know you
could make money on it I just thought it
was a place where you upload videos and
I thought well I have an audience here
maybe this audience will come see me in
person on a stage so I just made a show
and I put it in what I thought was funny
and then I did it live and the audience
tells you what works and what doesn't so
over time I figured out what bits works
and what things work really well on a
live in a live setting and what bits
work well on the Internet and just kind
of created a live show and this is where
you find yourself being a comedian you
know it you were it it seems to me that
I mean were you blindsided by all of a
sudden now I have to be a comedian you
know were you always funny the improv
skills that you have was that the piece
that I've also got that or no and I've
got to find this now yeah I think I grew
up going to improv shows my brother
always did improv stuff had improv shows
all the time in high school so I always
go to his shows and I also grew up
watching comedy the only things I would
watch Monty Python and Christopher Guest
movies like character II movies and
character II TV shows that's what I grew
up on and my dad's really funny and
really he's got a weird sense of humor
and the same with my brother so I just
kind of grew up in this kind of
off-kilter weird comedy environment I
guess and so it was something that was
in me that I didn't really know I had I
guess because I got on stage and improv
just came kind of natural to me I just
it was easy for me to improv and I'm
much more comfortable improving than I
was you know I realized this all those
years I had stress about memorizing
lines and trying to find a character
through a script was so hard for me and
when I can improv it's it's so much
easier it's it's something that I just
never knew I could do until I was forced
to do it in those first
Maranda shows done it before does that
require a move did you move to New York
I did move to New York I at first I was
going back and forth because I had the
job at Disneyland
and that was paying my bills and I was
performing as Miranda but I wasn't
getting paid I was just doing it because
I liked it and people were coming so I
was just doing shows and making
appearances and then I realized that
people would pay me to do what I was
doing and so I eventually I think I
traveled back and forth for like six
months from LA to New York I'd go like
once a month and perform and it was not
popular in LA at all like no one cared
about I tried to do a shot here I can no
one wanted to come like it was just not
it didn't work so I was like I gotta go
to New York that's where this is
happening so I lived in New York for
like a year and a half two years and
then and then that's when I was like
wait all the youtubers are in LA and
there's money to be made there so then I
came back here okay so is that because
your YouTube channels started to develop
you know more of a fan base that was you
know it seemed like you were following
the the live event kind of path but then
it that started to grow and started to
gain more weight yeah I didn't
understand YouTube I didn't get it like
the the reason I created the character
is cuz I didn't understand it you know I
was making fun of something I didn't
know anything about and so I was making
these videos and people were telling me
you can make money on the internet I was
like no you can I'm not making money on
the internet like you have to make money
by doing something else and that's why
I'm doing these live shows and I met my
now boyfriend in New York who's obsessed
with the u2 that's how he found me and
that's how we met and when we started
dating he started showing me all these
videos of people on YouTube the first
video he showed me was Shaytards channel
and I was like you know what what's his
name Josh Josh yeah no I I watched the
Paris vlog oh ok so here you are in
front of the Eiffel Tower giving the
whole story I know
so you know everyone can watch the video
if they want the the whole story of how
I met my boyfriend the mushy details oh
my gosh but he he was a fan of Miranda
and then stalked you as a human being
yeah
and said and me on Facebook through
facebook yeah and then I went to your
place you you replied to a fan message
on Facebook because he had a cute icon
no I thought he was gay when I saw his
icon I didn't think he was straight I
really didn't and I I just was like
something in me was like he had a right
this guy back and I didn't write anyone
back ever back then and I was just like
this he was interested in me and I guess
that's what I found intriguing because
most people don't care about it's fun
you had a low night
you needed up I had a huge glass of wine
[Music]
well five years later we're still
together so but yeah he's obsessed with
YouTube and he has been forever and he
showed me Shaytards and I was like this
family they just filmed themselves like
that's it and he was like yeah and look
at this person and this person and I
found myself I remember one night he he
came up from the bathroom came to the
bedroom he's like are you watching the
Shaytards
and I was like I love them like I'm
obsessed with this family and I don't
even know them like I feel like a freak
like I don't know these people and I
love them like you grow to love this
these people on YouTube and I just found
that so fascinating and I didn't realize
that there was a community on YouTube I
didn't understand that there are people
that were doing the same thing I was
doing and so that's kind of what
encouraged me to kind of move back to LA
and try to see if I could meet other
youtubers and be a part of the community
that I was watching online well the
interesting thing that was happening
seemingly simultaneously is that people
were really beginning to notice and make
a big deal out of your live show yeah I
mean like real theater critics no real
publications and real magazines not just
writing about like oh this
YouTube sensation but no this live show
is like a incredibly entertaining thing
yeah
so did you find yourself seeing to these
two things kind of blowing up at the
same time I mean okay YouTube's working
and now that I've got this live show
this is a legit operation kind of I
never really put much thought into the
YouTube videos ever until you know until
I moved out to LA and like really took
it seriously as a job the videos were
always just kind of like whatever and
kind of threw throw away but I wasn't
understanding why my shows weren't
selling out as much anymore I was I
didn't I was like where are these people
coming and so once I made the move to LA
and really invested time in the videos
then my shows just started selling out
because you know that's why they were
coming as they were there one in good
content I don't I don't know that it was
like overwhelming it was more exciting I
was like everything was kind of clicking
and falling into place I think I just
needed to I needed to understand YouTube
better and then everything just kind of
started working the shows started
selling out and I don't know it's I
think the live show is more fun and as a
it's more entertaining in the videos I
don't even watch my videos because
sometimes I'm like Ryan is so freaking
annoying like she's the girl is so
obnoxious
but this live show is so different it's
it's a lot different than the videos are
in it but it sounds like you're you're
moving forward on both fronts well
obviously they feed each other the
YouTube the YouTube momentum really
feeds into people buying tickets yeah
well I think that's all there is to I
don't think the live shows really feed
into the videos I think the videos feed
into the live shows the videos are so
important because if my videos aren't
good and people aren't watching know
it's going to come to the show and
that's what I want people to do I want
people to come to the live show because
I think that's where you can see talent
and really get entertained my favorite
part of doing a live shows is when
parents come up to me and they're like I
hated you my kids talk like you they
dress like you and I thought you were so
obnoxious and then after your show like
you're so talented you're so funny and
that to me is always like so I don't
know it just feels so nice to know like
I can convert someone being a fan
through the live show well yeah the
interesting thing about
thinking about in the YouTube aspect of
this and also the the live show is that
you know the character of Miranda really
makes the most sense as an online
personality right that was what you
thought of that's what you were thinking
this person who's there open loading
this video as if they're an authority on
rank voice lessons right right and then
but it perfect it perfectly translates
into the live show so it's an amazing
how it's amazing how it works out
I'm fascinated at the dynamic of the way
that Miranda has become who she is and
the way that you express yourself as
Miranda online in a couple of ways I
mean one is the fact that I mean I love
the Miranda Instagram disgusting but you
celebrate the things that most people
try to hide right in themselves right so
we're all trying to present ourselves in
a certain way through our Instagram
pictures and just the right angle I know
I've got to do this filter and all that
stuff and you do exactly the opposite we
were talking about this earlier today
and my theory was that you're probably a
much healthier person psychologically
you're as yourself because you have this
alter ego that just is all your
insecurities just out there just
celebrated on the internet yeah yeah
yeah it's true I think I think I wasn't
that way until kids started messaging me
and emailing me because originally the
the intention was to be hated and then I
started getting emails and letters that
were like I didn't like who I was and
you taught me to be confident
Miranda cuz you don't care what anybody
thinks you still love yourself no matter
what and it blew my mind that with this
stupid character who's a brat was
actually helping kids like love
themselves it was so weird I never
thought that would happen and I think
that's kind of when it started shifting
into you know she's still an idiot and
she's still super confident and
untalented but kids kind of find comfort
in her somehow I don't know and then I
started kind of to embrace it a little
bit more like pick the uglier angles
you know if I have I wake up with a huge
zit you know I'm gonna take a picture of
it you know I remember I got pinkeye a
couple years ago and the first thing I
thought when I woke up with pinkeye and
I was like crusted shows so gross I was
like this is going to make such a good
video I was so excited that I had
pinkeye so yeah it's been kind of fun
too
you know whenever something horrible
happens it's usually good there's an
interesting aspect to her character too
and that is that a lot of the things
that Miranda says are tweet tweets can
be misinterpreted as sexual very much so
and but she at the same time is a bit of
a prude and things that anything that's
risque is porn right and so it seems
like there's a hypocrisy there that
you're kind of trying to flesh out a
little yeah it's everyone thinks that
I'm being super sexual with these tweets
well and obviously I am trying to make
it seem like I'm talking about something
sexual but my take on it is that Miranda
is so oblivious that she doesn't realize
that it's that's what she said type of
moment she just doesn't see it that way
you know she has Joey talks about her
uncle I guess it's so weird saying she
it's me but yeah yeah she Miranda always
talks about her uncle and it's always
implied that their relationship is a
little too close and it's a little a
little rapey this is not drawing from so
no this is not drawing from anything but
I think of it as Miranda is just looking
at it like it's her uncle like my my
little four-year-old nephew looks at me
like is his auntie that he loves and he
would hug me and and we would we do have
tickle fights and we do love each other
and and he calls you auntie panties and
I don't know I think that's how Miranda
thinks of it she just loves her uncle a
lot and they're really good friends and
they play together all the time
and it's inappropriate but she doesn't
understand that it's inappropriate to be
that close to her uncle and I don't
think he means it in an inappropriate
way either I think it's just isn't there
sweetie weird so the so Miranda
relationship with her uncle is
seems inappropriate but it's not yeah
for the record well that's that's the
first time I've ever said that but that
is what I've always I've always known
that I've always known that Miranda
doesn't think there's not actually
anything bad going on in Miranda's life
she just always happens to say something
that makes it sound so foul and so like
yeah she's just oblivious like she
doesn't realize that she's right
what I mean when I when I see that
though and I also I know kind of when
you describe the girls that you're kind
of the experience that you're drawing on
and it sounds like probably some girls
who were self-righteous right and then
there's this unintentional you know
sexual innuendo that's kind of is coming
from that same voice to to me I just
definitely would maybe this is even a
subconscious thing that as you develop
the character but I definitely kind of
sense that there's like you've seen some
hypocrisy yeah for those people and so
she kind of embodies that yeah for sure
yeah that's I mean that's exactly it
she's everything she says is she's just
a huge hypocrite but she doesn't know
that she is you know she doesn't she's
not intending to be she just comes
across that way right
and another ironic thing that that has
happened is and you kind of hinted at
this earlier is that you become a bit of
a voice for the anti bullying nuts and
you actually kind of channel some of
those hate comments that you get and
read those as part of the live show yeah
I read a bunch of the hate mail as part
of the live show and the live show now
is like Miranda mentioned earlier it's a
self-help tour and she goes through all
the things in life and teaches kids how
to deal with relationships and bullies
and self-esteem and kind of goes through
all the steps on how to be a better
person of course all the time giving
terrible advice
but yeah bullies is a whole section of
the show and how to deal with bullies
and that was kind of inspired I just saw
these kids like I said earlier they're
just writing me these letters that were
breaking my heart and you know Miranda
was helping them laugh at the end of the
day when they were told to kill
themselves all day by these awful
bullies and it just and it kind of
changed everything for me that's when I
really started taking
more seriously the character and I
realize that it wasn't just these stupid
videos I was doing they were actually
like kids were you know inspired by this
girl with all the red lipstick right and
and there comes the evolution of you're
not just channeling the people that
annoy you right but you're but you're
now using that framework to then inspire
people which is who would have ever
thought yeah and I think a lot of it has
to do with the fact that I was able to
come out and say I'm kollene and I play
Miranda because kids then are like I
think kids feel like they they are in on
a secret or something like they know
that it's fake and they're excited by
that and then some of the kids subscribe
to my channel and they get to see me
there they get there like I can't
believe you're you're so strong to come
and be Miranda and be yourself and
whatever and I think that helped a lot
too is coming out and being myself and
when did you decide to come out come on
well it was a really slow process it was
really hard for me to do because I was
really obsessed with Miranda just being
Miranda and I wouldn't take interviews
as myself I wouldn't do anything like
when you were talking to that club owner
who offered you that one night and you
said yes you did all that in character
no I guess no that I didn't do in care
okay like in his office yeah I was in
his office it was different
that's that could be taken that was
branded so anyway I was it was it was
very slow process I think what's it
started because I was watching the
Shaytards and started to watch other
youtubers and I had my own channel that
I would upload performance videos to
everyone small so my parents could see
at home you know upload those videos of
you singing so YouTube is where I did
that and so just with that channel I
decided um a few Christmases ago I was
just gonna try vlogging for a week with
my family and it was really exciting to
see kids watch that and be interested in
me in my life and so I think that kind
of changed it I was like it's okay to be
myself people are gonna be mad they're
not gonna stop watching Miranda in fact
it kind of helped
the Miranda numbers go up a little bit
because people were searching all the
time is Miranda real Miranda sings
without the lipstick they wanted to see
who I was and a lot of people told me
not to do that a lot of people were like
don't do that it'll Miranda will die if
you say who you are so I was really
scared to do it and it was really slow
but eventually started doing
Miranda interviews and kollene
interviews at the same time our you know
I was it was easier for me to meet fans
not as Miranda that took a long time to
I wouldn't leave the bit the building
until everyone was gone so I didn't want
them to see me as me but now I'm I don't
care I was really nervous to do it but
when it happened it wasn't like it was a
specific day Rose like I'm gonna do it
I'm just gonna be myself it was really
slow it took a while for me to be
comfortable with it and I'm still kind
of weird about I feel like I'm still
trying to like it's still hard for me
you know like you guys asked me doesn't
want to talk about Colleen and I was
like no I don't know because it's still
like I'm still like holding on to it a
little bit like Miranda people need to
think Moran is real even though no you
know everyone knows right way now that
your your you know you're uploading two
videos a week to each channel right yeah
and you're obviously talented not only
as a comedian but as a singer and a
performer so you know how do you how do
you balance that when you think about
the future and you're you're like okay
well I've got these two tracks you know
I hope that Miranda will keel over at
some point or this is I'm gonna take
this all the way like what are you ya
know I don't want to kill Miranda I
think I will just keep doing whatever
the audience wants to see and right now
you know I can't believe it but people
are still watching Miranda people still
like Miranda as far as the future I you
know a lot of people think that I want
Miranda to go away so that I can shine
and show off my talent but like I don't
I really don't care about that at all
like I of course I want to keep making
people laugh because that's what I like
the most and I would love to do other
characters and show it off other
characters and I'm I'm writing stuff
right now with my brother to hopefully
show off of their characters in the
future soon but it's you know I I think
and will live as long as people want to
watch she's gonna get pregnant and get
that's exciting you know she's gonna go
through it all with me are you pregnant
I'm this is the announcement I'm
pregnant guys okay I wanna that's the
key to Varsha working is somebody's got
to get pregnant on this show well but
but you know a man wait that you should
develop a character as a man oh it's in
the works I know I really I really have
one and I'm really excited about it this
um I know all about it
oh you do I don't I was just gonna be so
surprised because having to hold anyone
I think I'm encouraging you which is
what you're saying about wanting to
develop other characters because I think
a lot of people do ask Oh once they say
well oh she's got this great voice she's
got this background when is she going to
what are you gonna do your own thing
like why don't you do more more singing
on your own channel and really boost
that but me personally selfishly I'm
like yeah why don't you develop more
characters Miranda I wanna yeah Merman
done my man done no dancing that's what
I want to and I think a guy character
well I have created a guy character and
I'm super excited to us about him I will
tell you about him um is he out anywhere
he is is he
you mean on the internet yet doesn't
live on the internet yet he the plan is
for him to live on the Internet I'm
writing a show with my brother and it's
gonna have a lot of different characters
and one of the characters that we're
developing right now who might he might
change you might become someone else but
it's a pastor and he's based on someone
in my family that I I don't think he'll
hear this he has very good intentions
he's really sweet but he just kind of
always does everything wrong you know is
she's just a dad you know he's always
happy and jolly you know he says those
horrible dad jokes and he's just just
kind of not he's kind of an idiot so a
preacher dad yeah he's well but he's
never actually a pastor he's always like
the associate pastor at a church
I think it's fired from every church he
goes
he just always does something wrong he's
too old to be the youth pastor or he
just doesn't have any miss for it yeah
he makes everyone wear nametags
everywhere they go and he's just kind of
always inappropriate but on accident
like at a funeral he'll start to sing a
pop song just because he just learned it
on his guitar you know just like what's
the what's the look of can you tell us
the name of this guy
well the name might change I mean I know
what the name is right now but it's like
so early if I'll tell you I'll tell you
it's pastor Jim okay working title
working title
what is his look pastor Jim look um he's
got a lot of hair it's like a you know
salt-and-pepper grey like kind of a
comb-over but it's with a lot of hair
yeah and we know your hair kind of put
up in my hair ya know we were playing
with the look the other day my brother
and I were trying on costumes and wigs
and stuff and trying to find this guy
and we really don't want him to have
facial hair but I think we're gonna have
to unless we do come some sort of
prosthetic on my face because my face
just looked too girly no matter what we
did we put eyebrows on me and sideburns
and I still just like had a girl face so
I think he's going to end up having a
mustache but he's I don't know I really
like this character I think he's really
it's a very he's a relatable character
because everyone has a friend who has
that dad it's just like oh please leave
the room like you're so annoying he
doesn't gay but he's just always jolly
so you can't really be mad at him but
he's so obnoxious but he's so happy
while he's being obnoxious that you
can't really hate him that's one of the
characters yeah but I have other
character boy character ideas that's
just the one we're developing the most
right now and this is with YouTube in
mind or maybe but yeah yes no I mean my
hope is to kind of do something that's
combining television and YouTube
together so that's kind of the plan but
he will live on YouTube in some capacity
hmm so you're you're pitching it Maranda
television show yeah what you're saying
pretty much
yes well you should be well we're trying
to but I mean who isn't pitching a show
in Hollywood want you to be back again
oh I will be pastor June no I want to be
the lead pastor alright I'll be the
youth pastor here we go got it I go back
to what I said earlier I think that
everybody needs an alter ego that they
can just get it out yeah I mean I think
that you're you're blessed because of
this I mean that is our theory for why
it probably makes you a healthier person
to be a people to just get what you want
somebody it's not yourself it's so funny
because I start the show as the live
show as myself and then I change onstage
in to Miranda in the middle of a song
and I go onstage as me and I am always
so nervous like I've done this hundreds
of times and every time I go on stage
I'm shaking I'm so nervous and the
second I put the lipstick on I don't
care like the rest of the show I'm a
tease I'm not nervous at all like so
weird how
just a little mindset of like now I'm
this person who can get away with
anything and there's no nerves anymore
do you have an aversion to lipstick in
general as Colleen I mean is it like
okay well I can't wear a duck here you
can't put red lipstick on no matter what
do you what do you yeah I I kind of
learned that I posted an Instagram
picture a couple years ago of me wearing
red lipstick at like I think it was New
Year's Eve or something and all the
comments for like you Miranda like
you're wearing realistic yeah so I I
don't wear red lipstick anymore no and
and how does it the last thing I'm
interested in how this translates into
your romantic relationship with your
boyfriend is he ever like you know baby
can you be marine you know he you know
he's very gross he's like he's very
sweet and wonderful he's such a Southern
gentleman but when I'm Miranda and I'm
doing a video he'll be like I love you
and I don't understand how someone that
pretty can be so hideous you look
disgusting like he just he thinks
Miranda is the grossest thing in the
world but there was one time I remember
we weren't kissing and and he like made
a Miranda face at me like I you know I
pulled away from the kiss and I said I
love you or something sweet and girly
and annoying and he kind of made him
around to face and so I made one back at
him and he was like whoa he's like never
do that again he freaked out he like
pushed me away from him okay and I
haven't done it since so maybe I should
just try it out maybe faster Gemma work
for me I'm gonna go freshen up in the
bathroom this has been fine this is uh
wise for me to think about here about
creating an alter ego about all that
stirol' yeah extremely fascinating
thanks for hanging out thanks for having
me letting us gain some insight and you
get to sign the table twice no me too
yeah so you know this is uh I'll sign it
by Miranda's name there it is our ear
biscuit with Miranda and Colleen I
really enjoyed getting to know both of
them and I'm still amazed at how I see
them so distinct who wouldn't have been
time with I had a longer period of time
Colleen I think that's pretty obvious
you know it only is the type of person I
could actually be friends with as a
person Miranda somebody that's very
entertaining to be around but you kind
of feel like you have to be on your
guard the whole time you feel like I
don't want to I don't want to make a I
don't want to say something that she
thinks is stupid or apologizing for her
to everyone else that the two of you may
be running into that's that would be my
issue with Miranda
Oh like I'm sorry she didn't mean it
that way um etc etc or etc I don't know
how to say that word either but that's a
different thing that's like a Miranda
tweet I also really appreciated coing
story in the sense that she seized
particular moments and made it happen
you
no she's getting emails with this viral
video in a certain theatre community in
New York they wanted to come okay yes
I'm gonna come to you and I'm going to
do this thing and then the club owners
like can do you have a show she's like
yes but she didn't you know but she just
made it happen
she had confidence pivotal moments where
you have the right amount of confidence
I think that was that was the key and
and a unearthing an improv skill that
untrained but innate yeah and I always
appreciate it when people from
traditional media sources recognize
talent on YouTube because I feel like
there is so much you know I feel like
they're just because people haven't gone
through the traditional media loopholes
and gone through that gauntlet you know
and got the traditional auditions and
all that stuff you mean in theater in
this case yeah just like there's these
you know people staged performance you
read what people who know a lot about
theater and know a lot about Broadway
have to say about her they don't talk
about her like oh this girl's on YouTube
and second class theater yes it is she
gets people to come to her but thing
because she's on YouTube on that YouTube
thing but no it's like this is a
legitimately entertaining experience
that transcends anything that you could
experience online with her which is
already great which is what I know and
which is what I find hilarious so you
know it's just encouraging I just I like
to to hear stories about people who have
done something so that comes so
naturally to them and has been such a
success on a broad scale and she's
coming to Anaheim soon so this show is
gonna be there so we miss Santa Barbara
but I want to go I think we should we
should we should certainly go see one
ask Linda Schmidt a day at Disney
together just me and you and then we and
Miranda we right no just me and you we
right it's a small world things like
that hang out you know get some Mickey
mouse-shaped pancakes and then we head
over to the Miranda sings show can we
get the Mickey Mouse hats yeah they're
free they're not free are they I think
there's a dispenser yeah you just have
to sing a little
you have to sing once you wish upon a
star and then it
pop-tarts when you wish upon a steer
that turns you wish upon a star
dispenser I do know that Walt Disney had
to smell a popcorn
shot into Disney World because it makes
people buy more stuff and you know what
the smell is actually made out of
burning horses little gnome night next
time you go burning horses think of
burning horses like a glue plant
scenario yeah I was gonna say glue
plants don't smell like popcorn or
Disneyworld you don't think they do yeah
how did how did that happen I don't know
well anyway you should you should follow
and watch Miranda and kollene at their
respective places on the internet they
have distinct Instagram accounts Twitter
accounts YouTube channels they are
essentially two different people people
still think they're two different people
but as we have proven today they are
thanks for listening oh really did this
your biscuit I was gonna say it was one
person it is it is this one you'd be
wrong her name is Colleen playing a
character and there's actually only one
person between me and you maybe it's
time we break that news his name is
Roger hi this is Roger I do a really
good impersonation of two different
people and I look very different this is
me Roger right now - yep so this has
been Roger hope you enjoyed this year
biscuit I will see you again next week
Roger Roger
[Music]
[Music]